[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
steve kornacki is the national political
correspondent for nbc news
msnbc nbc news the election
map expert and it feels like you became
an overnight sensation but took you a
long time to become an overnight
sensation steve thanks for joining us
what do people say to you when they see
you on the street
um thanks for having me happy to be here
um well
i guess one of the things about life in
the pandemic is you don't see too many
people on the streets so
um the few i've run into though yeah the
map guy the numbers guy
you know um still a few every now and
then they'll say hey it's chris hayes so
i still get that
how do you become the election map
expert
um you know honestly it's something i
it's a role i kind of always wanted it's
um
it's one that's kind of um i think come
into being in the last 20 years or so
it's funny when i go back and look at
i love looking at kind of archive um you
know
archive news footage archive sports
footage i like looking at stuff from the
past
um i realized you know just 20 years ago
back in 2000
you know tim rushert was here at nbc and
you know the famous moment in the 2000
election when it all came down to
florida a couple hundred votes
russia didn't have an electronic board
he had a he had a white board
and he just wrote down florida florida
florida and i think that's in the
smithsonian now but
i mean that was technology just 20 years
ago so this you know the idea of having
a board with real-time data with numbers
it's really come in in the last 10 15
years but
um you know since it's kind of been
around i had my eye on it and i got
lucky about um
it was 2014 actually 2014 my boss here
called me up about two months before the
election said hey we need somebody to do
this
you think you could do something with it
i said yeah i think i could so that was
the start of it for me
how do you memorize all the counties
um you know i think it's just good
old-fashioned you know
staring at it memorizing it repeating it
pulling out the map
trying again um you know it helps i
haven't been to
all these places i've not been to more
counties than i've been to
but um you know one thing in the last
six years i i will
you know i vacationed in ohio about two
years ago just to learn the state to
learn the counties to get a better sense
of it that way
um that helps but obviously i haven't
done that anywhere so really it's just
it's like cramming for a final it's just
memorization
and repetition and it the the memory
kind of builds who's better on the touch
screen or you or john king
oh come on he's john king's the original
um
and you know nothing but respect for him
and honestly i haven't seen
a cnn election night since i've been
doing this because there's no time to
watch it so
i i'm not qualified to say you're kind
of like uh
lamar jackson and he's michael vick like
he might have been the
the original and then you're an up
updated version of it
that's and he's still doing it hey and
fox has someone doing it and i i don't i
don't want to get into anything with
anybody
uh i try not to make enemies how did you
end up on football night in america
you know i got a call um about a week
after the election
uh from my boss here saying that you
know the folks at nbc sports
um you know wanted to you know talk to
me had a couple ideas
um i was very excited to to hear that
and um
you know so we've been talking for about
two weeks before it and um you know came
up with the idea i think um
you know that hey this is it's december
in the nfl it's it's when the playoff
race really gets serious and
i think there was a it seemed like there
really was a parallel there between
road to 270 and an electoral map for a
presidential election and wrote the
playoffs it's all about scenarios it's
all about
if this state goes this way or if this
team does this there really did seem to
be an overlap there
what give me a couple of teams that
aren't maybe being mentioned as playoff
teams but you think they have a better
chance than maybe
a couple of teams that we think are
going to make the playoffs
yeah i mean i i don't know if this is
now too counterintuitive watching the
game last night i know they were talking
about this a lot but baltimore
you know sitting there right now at
seven and five would not be in the
playoffs if they started today if you
just look at their schedule
they get cleveland next week and after
that it's it's three teams with losing
records
you know so they've got a really easy
schedule down the stretch it's not hard
to see them getting
you know to 10 wins and you compare that
like to miami who would be in right now
in the sixth spot you know miami a game
ahead of baltimore understanding sitting
there at eight and four
miami doesn't have a single game left
against a team with a losing record i
mean starting with kansas city next week
so
you know the sort of the burdens on
miami to show they can hang on to that
position against the kind of competition
they're taking
and it just seems like the opportunity
is there for baltimore to leapfrog a
bunch of teams here just based on that
schedule
when did you become fascinated with
numbers
you know it was um when i was in first
grade it was the uh i could tell you it
was the 1985-86
nba season i grew up outside boston um i
would go outside get the boston globe
every morning and read the celtics box
course and that was the best celtics
team ever that was
the big three bird mchale parish and um
celtics box scores that season and then
summer of 86 was the red sox that was
the you know with the buckner year so
the red sox were a thing that year i got
into baseball box scores
and um you know that that kind of
started numbers for me and then a couple
years later
um you know kind of got into politics
really about middle school and
kind of the numbers aspect of it too i
guess but the pressure on election night
is different
like you can be on football night in
america and you might make a mistake and
it's football night in america
but election night how much pressure did
you feel
oh yeah yeah no there's there's a lot
there and this year was
this year was more intense because
there's just this added variable this
year of
people were voting by mail and we knew
the people voting by mail were going to
be overwhelmingly biden
and the people who were going out you
know and voting in person at their
precinct on election day
we knew that was going to be pretty
heavily trump and there was just this
variable as the numbers would come in
from a lot of places of
okay are we looking at votes that were
cast by mail here are we looking at
votes that were cast
in person today are we looking at a mix
of both because that that question
and trying to be on top of that
information was key to understanding
everything that was happening and that
was just something
there's no at a certain level there's no
preparing for it because we've never had
that before in an election and so
yeah i felt um i always feel a lot of
anxiety before these things this year i
felt
um about 10 times more than i have in
the past how do you come
off as unbiased i mean it's
it's probably a cliche but the the
numbers don't lie um
you know at a certain point and and you
know i can if i
if i have a um it's true in sports it's
it's true covering politics if you're
cheering for a team in sports you know
there's no denying if they
they lose 17 14. there's no time left on
the clock then they've lost the game's
over you got to talk about the next game
um you know i think the same is true and
you know covering an election it
wouldn't do me any good to be
um to be trying to you know kind of push
it to one side or to push it to the
other as the numbers come in because
they are gonna
ultimately all come in and we'll all be
able to see what it is what happens if
the touch screen goes down
what was uh the game plan it's it's
happened before it's it's how i made the
uh tonight show um for the first time in
my life
uh this was in the 2016 election um i
was doing a segment
and the board went blank completely
blank but the
the writing function on it with my
finger still worked
and the camera's still rolling nobody's
telling me to stop so i'm like i got to
improvise here
and we were talking about sort of you
know road to 270. so i said okay i'll
draw a crude
outline of the united states and i can
kind of talk about the different regions
so i tried to draw the united states and
it looked like
part of the it turned out it looked like
part of the mayo reproduction
jimmy fallon noticed it that was my
first uh
you say overnight fame or something that
was my first taste of it
okay but how do you how do you react to
something like that i i know you i think
you made
majored in uh tv and film at boston
university but
you know now i'm famous and i'm infamous
and so how do you process that
yeah that was the thing about that was
like i didn't even realize it until
uh things started popping up on online
i really didn't think i had done
anything and then it was one of those
obvious once i saw it i was like okay i
see how
how everybody saw that and of course i
was on with um one of my colleagues here
hallie jackson and i think you know she
was standing next to me the whole time
and you could see when you look at the
tape she recognized it the whole time
when something like that happens my view
is it's like just you know just
just own it and you know i kind of
stepped in it and i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna make excuses for it i'll just you
know i'll laugh along with everybody
because
it's kind of ridiculous well it's it's
best to grab it and own it
before somebody else does i always tell
people then
and this has happened to me on numerous
occasions you make a mistake
own it and then they then you take away
the weapon that somebody else has when
they're going to point that out so you
you did the right thing where you just
go hey i did it
uh i move on yeah and i i think you're
right and that's what i try to do when
it's a little bit more serious than a
a drawing like that um you know we've
gotten numbers wrong we've gotten you
know we'll get vote returns that come in
and it turns out there's corrections and
they they change completely and yeah i
know i do think that's key with the
audience just in terms of credibility
um don't try to pretend if you if you
made a fool yourself don't try to
pretend you didn't
based on the numbers who would you put
in the super bowl
can you do something that far out of
projection it's
i i guess this would be the the the
steve kornacki gut numbers because i
haven't seen the updated you know we've
been our partner is pff pro football
focused and i haven't seen our updated
numbers after last night but just my
my gut on it would be kansas city you
know in the afc
and i think you know probably
conventional wisdom at this point
um in the nfc i'm kind of liking the way
green bay is playing right now
okay well wait is this based off
anything or is this
this is your goal this is this is my gut
feeling and it's
a sense of where the numbers i haven't
seen the the updates but my guess is
between pittsburgh losing
you know kansas city hanging out against
denver my sense is the numbers are going
to shift pretty dramatically in the afc
here
give me your favorite county in the
united states
uh that's a good question um
my favorite county well i gotta be
partial to middlesex county
massachusetts um where i was born
um is there a favorite name of a county
that
you love to say there's otagome county
in uh wisconsin which has one of the you
know the funny wisconsin has
the best county name you know there's
also you know where ann arbor is in
michigan washtenaw county
um you know when you get to the upper
midwest i think you get a lot of those
sort of native american names and you
get uh those are the ones where
sometimes i in my early days of doing
this i would call the um
when i wasn't sure in the pronunciation
the day of an election i would just call
up like the county clerk's office just
to see how they answered the phone and
that would be my answer
yeah that's what's difficult is just
making sure because i i always point out
that
there was a movie the thomas crown
affair with piers brosnan
and they mentioned in the movie that
somebody is from
uh lima ohio well it's it's
lima ohio and if you're from that area
you're like
how could you screw that up so you have
to make sure you get it right
we might not know the county you're
talking about but the people who live in
that county
know the county you're talking about the
locals do and some of them are very
you know counter-intuitive you go down
like san antonio is in texas
it looks like bexar county it's bear
county b-e-x-a-r
and it's bear county that one took me a
while to learn
hey congrats on the success there steve
and hopefully uh we'll see on football
are you doing football night in america
now the rest of the regular season yeah
it sounds like we're gonna do it through
the um through the rest of the season
you know follow the playoff race look at
the numbers change
and um it's very excited for it all
right just be careful what you draw okay
yeah thanks i think i learned my lesson
there thank you steve that's steve
kornacki
and he of course works for nbc their
national political correspondent
msnbc and he is the election map
expert